des petites sculptures sous le regard
des monumentsales statues de l'Orangerie
cet engage réhabilité à Mantes-la-Jolie
accueille actuellement un chantier de
restauration pour quatre oeuvres du
château de Versailles à l'occasion des
Journées Européennes des Métiers d'Art
le public était invité ce mardi 28 mars
à participer à un atelier de modelage
avec une artiste plasticienne objective
reproduire des fragments de ces figures
représentant des dieux et déesses de la
mythologie grecque j'essaye de leur déjà
leur faire découvrir la matière leur
expliquer que la l'argile est utilisée
souvent aussi comme une esquisse comme
une ébauche dans un projet comme celui
qui est derrière moi beaucoup plus
volumineux c'est une des plus vieilles
méthodes de sculpture en fait on va
mettre des sourcils comme ça et après on
a un nez
au sein de ce chantier exposition le
réveil de la pierre les 8 créateurs en
herbe ont pu modeler un pied ou un
visage l'occasion déguisé son regard et
sa dextérité grâce à un matériau
malléable permettant les erreurs de
débutants
je pense à toutes les travails qu'il
faut il faut faire là pour le
pornovation là c'est énorme ça va être
très intéressant de découvrir ce que
sont ces métiers qui ne sont pas connus
qui sont des métiers de l'ombre mais
d'excellence de l'artisanat qui font
appel à des compétences tout à fait
remarquables d'autres ateliers seront
organisés durant ces journées
européennes des métiers d'art découverte
ce dimanche 2 avril des savoir-faire
d'un tailleur de pierre et d'un
conservateur restaurateur